chen la mort d'henri troyat
l'académicien français de son vrai nom
léon tara sauf avait écrit une centaine
d'ouvragés dont la règne pour lequel il
avait reçu le prix goncourt en 1938 ses
obsèques auront lieu vendredi
sophie jouve daniel levy henri troyat a
longtemps écrit debout devant santa me
tue pitre géant par sa stature et sa
puissance de travail
il aimait s'entourer de souvenirs
évoquant la steppe russe de son enfance
le petit arabe sauf à 9 ans lorsqu'il
fut la révolution et débarque à paris
licence de droit en poche il prend le
pseudonyme d'henri troyat et publie ses
premiers livres qui seront tout de suite
des succès à 27 ans il décroche le prix
goncourt
sa carrière est lancée mon dernier roman
la barre inya et voici ce qu'il donne
une fois imprimés ce prêt les ratures et
très corrigé gris sur un seul côté de la
page
et lui il écrivait si fort et si si
volontiers avec tant de bonheur qu'il
est qu'elle écrivait il avait de la
danse il avait dix volumes d'avant sur
les éditeurs c'est un homme qui avait
remplacé la vie par la littérature
je crois que pendant soixante dix ans il
a écrit six heures phare académiciens 48
ans le plus jeune de son époque troyat
c'est d'abord le souffle épique des
grandes sagas tels les semailles et les
moissons
mais c'est aussi le biographe insatiable
qui ressuscite aussi bien catherine de
russie
dostoïevski tolstoï que flaubert ou
balzac vos vêtements français est
tellement adapté à mon corps que si je
devais l'enlever je m'attacherai la peau
je dis cela et en même temps je sais
qu'il ya un petit enfant russe qui dort
au plus profond de moi jamais grisé par
la gloire troyat qui se définissait
avant tout comme un conteur aura écrit
plus d'une centaine de livres l'un des
auteurs les plus féconds de sa
génération